I saw the movie again last night come on
I'm so happy I saw that you were
sneaking into theaters yesterday so what
happened what was the reaction like I
mean honestly it was everybody was
laughing you know it was they'll yelling
at the screen you know I'm saying like
the gas the one-liners everything was
working so it was cool to kind of see it
with a you know seeing a normal audience
it's not out of premiere at a press
junket so I mean they were really
engaged in interacting with the film so
it was good to see I know you were
nervous I know you were like I've never
played a villain before now I have you
can you breathe a sigh of relief when
you're seeing what people are saying and
folks are dressing up and going crazy
yeah I mean it is a little relaxing to
know that people are really really
liking the performance it was something
I've never really done before so I was
anxious to kind of see how how they
played in it and if it worked and it
felt good so you know it's a it's going
okay now what kind of game you got on
the court we know what you're doing on
the screen but what can you do on the
course yeah play ball but I'm coaching
this year cuz you know Kevin Hart tried
to do both he tried to coach and then
come in like the Willis Reed surprise at
the end and take it over like this if my
team is down yeah I'm saying fourth coy
and they lead me I will come out of
retirement if they need me but other
than that I'm gonna let them do their
thing
now will you bench somebody will you
[ __ ] somebody in a second oh and her be
okay